these robots are testing various
substances they work day in and day out
around the clock there are hundreds of
labs here it's a painstaking process and
there's no rushing it
it's a hands-off operation this is a
culture dish which has a thousand five
hundred thirty six tiny wells I don't
have to count them I know exactly how
many there are a biological experiment
is being carried out in every single one
of these wells the entire process starts
when we find a chemical molecule that we
want to adapt that's what's happening in
these culture dishes we're testing
millions of substances looking for a
place to begin the scientists are
testing three million substances hunting
for a promising molecule if they do find
the proverbial needle in a haystack the
next step is optimizing it it's a bit
like playing with Lego blocks you've got
a structure made out of ten Lego blocks
in various different colors you add a
Lego block here remove another one over
there in three years your structure
might not bear any resemblance to your
starting point but it's more effective
stronger longer-lasting a substance is
optimized it's tested on animals if it
still looks promising its tested on
humans that takes another six to eight
years and there's no guarantee of
success
buyers research focuses on drugs that
treat common diseases like
cardiovascular disease and cancer both
count pushka is a member of the board
responsible for health care the division
has 55,000 employees and sales of 18
billion euros a year we focus on areas
where there's still a medical need we
can and should focus our research only
on areas where there's still an unmet
need and where no optimal medical
therapy exists when I'm and the second
issue is that we have to make
sure that what we're doing is useful for
the company we're a business and we're
responsible to our shareholders so we
need to focus on areas where we'll
eventually make a profit which we can
then reinvest in research and
development Plus who knows that
competition is stiff and a patent only
lasts 20 years that's not a lot when you
consider that the patent begins when the
drug is still in development when in
these outside during those 20 years the
new product the medication has to
establish itself as a therapy and a
medical treatment boxes
to make sure that happens we invest in
marketing the medication we also provide
education to physicians who need
information about how to use the new
drug therapy effectively it's been a
successful strategy for buyer and for
helmet Hanning to a new drug is a rare
discovery and hunting is one of the
lucky few when it went on the German
market I went to the pharmacy and ask
them to show it to me it was just so
hard to believe the other scientists
hope they'll be lucky to but only 1% of
even the most promising substances will
become a drug treatment in the end